help us change the culture by buying our
latest single from tim cast records only
ever wanted by clicking the link in the
description below
from the post millennial
vote republican joe rogan and how
americans can protect your freedom well
everybody knows that dr joe rogan is who
you go to for your political and medical
advice i'm joking by the way calm down
youtube and uh here's what happened joe
rogan and green bay packers quarterback
aaron rodgers got into it into the got
into the harms of covet policies in a
recent episode of the experience and
rogan took the opportunity to blast
democrats and give a boost to
republicans
vote republican he said in response to
roger's question about what americans
should do about it quote
no one who was alive today had ever
experienced a true pandemic and i'm
hoping that now that this is over people
are going to you know recognize that
some serious errors were made and not
repeat those that's the best you can get
out of it so what do you tell those
people roger said
vote republican rogan said rogers
chuckled that's what a lot of them are
going to do anyway more than a million
people transferred over the republican
party i think in 2021 alone but you know
you look at guys like ron desantis who
kept florida open and had some pretty
reasonable policies in terms of like
what to do about covet and you know he
mapped it on television full stop
desantis did not keep it completely open
they did shut down but eventually faster
than everybody than many others did
reopen there were a bunch of red states
that never locked down christine for
instance they threw a parade for her
he was widely criticized for this where
he was saying we need to protect our
elders we need to make sure that medical
care is available for those people and
everyone else should be able to do
whatever you want to do and protect your
freedom now this is the crazy thing
joe has taken the bold step of laughing
and telling people to vote republican
he's often said he was a liberal he's
defended all of that
he's like people call me right wing but
i'm a liberal and he is he's like he's
in favor of universal basic income
now he's telling people to vote
republican but i feel like it's not even
an endorsement of
the republican party i feel like the
overton window has shifted so far left
that it's it's almost like a rejection
and vote against the people that are
going so far liberal um i don't think
it's like you know a typical endorsement
of the party as a whole yeah there was a
uh this graph that we've showed a long
time ago where it's like where the
political parties are and they created
this this spectrum where it was economic
left and right and and um i think like
social justice left and right the
democrats were all extremely hyper
concentrated in racial and economic
socialist policy and the republicans
were spread out away from the social
justice stuff but varying from socialist
all the way to laissez faire capitalists
that was crazy gotta be careful about
calling leftism liberalism as well
because there is an idea of like
liberalism is you want to be free and
open with ideas and let kids kind of
explore the world but sexualizing
children is not i don't think that's
liberty i don't think that that's doing
justice to children it can warp them in
their later years this is this is i
think on par with what imagine noise
refers to as like up and down or
something
is it does he call it up and down i
think so like the axes yeah because like
the the you know he talks about how
maybe maybe maybe maybe he doesn't say
it but he talks about how religious
zealotry is not left or right
it's it's it's idea it's something
different and if you've got people who
have a cult ideology that doesn't really
fit into any of these political specters
like political sections or segments then
we got to acknowledge that it's not
liberal it's not left like jacobin for
instance they're socialists they're
leftists but they're pro free speech
they rag on the fbi all the time they
rag on the democrats and i'm like okay
cool you know i can respect that i guess
i don't agree with the socialism part
though so i guess
i think rogan's i mean in the context of
these statements he's talking about the
pandemic right he's talking about the
way that kovit was handled and i think a
lot of people are just fed up and they
see through just exactly everything at
this point i mean take a look at fauci's
riding off into the sunset in december
apparently they're shifting gears and
shifting the simulation politico is
putting out articles literally changing
the narrative blaming the vaccine roll
out on trump now so all the negative
effects and all that will be blamed on
president trump coming forward dr burks
is coming out and saying oh we knew the
whole time they weren't effective
they're saying this the cdc coming out
and saying the same thing there was a
the uh the cnn i don't know if she was
some kind of medical something that was
like huge on masks
yeah she was like huge on now she's come
out and said that now she's come out and
said the masks uh damaged my own child
so like it's like i think people get
exhausted at some point like it goes
beyond politics it's like i'm i'm being
driven in this direction i'm being
driven in that direction cnn keeps
telling me this okay now they're
changing their mind and it's just like
this this constant just exhaustion of
the mind where the cult begins to push
you and push you and i think the people
that are waking up are just getting fed
up it's got to break down at some point
right like this is it that someone
posted a meme and it was just like it
was janine garofalo's quote i think it
was and it said something like if you
vote the only way someone can become a
republican is there something wrong with
them you you can't be an open-minded
well you know thinking individual and
vote republican or something like that
and i'm like that's not an argument
about anything like you're literally
being like the republican bad like you
didn't say that tell me why they're mad
and why you think they're wrong to be
mad but that idea i'm like if that's
what i don't know if that quote is
actually farmer it was a meme right but
this idea is laughable that people would
share it like
you've fallen for every major hoax
that's happened every single one if
there's one thing that gives me a
that gives me hope that keeps me
white-pilled and reassures me that we
are on the correct side is that we've
not fallen for all of these hoaxes maybe
once or twice we were like hey you know
what's that all about and then it comes
out like oh okay that was a hoax but the
but the left and liberals every single
hoax every time and you know you know
what it is i think a lot of it they want
to fall for they wanted jesse's mullet
story to be true it was great
but it was just so glaringly obvious the
dude was making up nonsense
anybody anybody with a brain so at what
point
do the cult leaders
lose that ability to convince
ignorant people
that these hoaxes are real at what point
do the masses just say like dude
you've lied every single time i'm over
it i have some friends on facebook from
los angeles back when i was doing a lot
of theater you called consider them
liberal i guess i don't know but we were
talking about the student loans like
where's the money coming from and some
people like i heard that it was gonna be
they were just gonna charge it off to
the tax to the loan companies i don't
know i don't know where it's coming from
i'm like yo look
the uh peter ducey questions the the
spokes what's her what's her title
karine the press secretary that's her
the press secretary where's the money
coming from she dodges the question
three times in the interview i love how
nobody knows her name and so when i i
know i can't forget about it
yeah yeah
i post the video to my friends in this
liberal chat wherever you were mostly
and everyone's just like silent in awe
at realizing that they're snowballing
the american people they're gonna end up
charging people tax money to pay for
their own loans ahead of time so it's
like an accelerated repayment to sallie
mae like that's unconscionable and i
cannot imagine that'll pass like if if
biden's proposing it shoot it down
because that is not you don't make us
pay our own loans back early that
doesn't do anybody any justice i i don't
understand like the rejection of like
knowing how things are going to play out
like everybody should have a house right
everybody should have a meal everybody
should have their loans forgiven but
like it doesn't work it's not pragmatic
like why are they so behold why are they
so stuck to these these uh these
fantasies i think i think they actually
want the opposite and i don't mean the
average person i think the average
liberal democrat liberal or democrat or
leftist they genuinely want people to
have these things but they're easily led
astray if you look at capitalism
uh people have air conditioners people
have refrigerators people have clean
running water people have nicer and
nicer things now we got people sitting
down with widescreen you get a wide like
75 inch tv for like 500 bucks it's crazy
go to best buy it's like everybody's got
one yeah capitalism is making everybody
very very wealthy but you know what i
think
i think a lot of the higher profile
people don't like that you will own
nothing and you will be happy they're
looking at the over consumption they
don't want everyone to live in luxury
they think that causes problems that
causes climate change so what are they
saying they want to get rid of the
airlines surprise surprise the airlines
are like spiraling out of control with
mass retirements and cancellations
they're getting what they want they
don't want regular people to be able to
do these things and here's what it boils
down to they're always ragging on you
see them ragging like jeff bezos has 130
million dollar yacht or whatever but
what they really what they what these
powerful elites these these climate
change people
and this is not an indictment or a it's
not support or opposition to the idea of
climate change
they want you all to stop having access
to vehicles to gasoline to cheap food
so that they can keep access to all
those things if you aren't allowed to
fly
then they don't have to worry about when
they fly because their contribution to
climate change is minimal you see them
all flying in private jets all the
private jets flew to europe for the
climate change conference you know what
they're really saying with what they're
they're speaking words right but the
real the real thing they're saying is
how can we take it all away from the
working class people so that we can keep
it right and i think i think
it's it's foolish to believe that
tyranny somehow just
uh disappears
out of out of planet earth or out of
society or out of mankind right it's
like it never leaves there's always
going to be like an entity of tyranny
somewhere on the globe wherever you look
and i think if americans literally
believe that
like if you're sitting there saying you
know that could never happen to america
like you're just you've lost your mind
like you're losing you have a losing
mindset whether you're on the left or
whether you're on the right like even if
you're someone that's like you know i
just i i love my right wing politician
and that that person is just always
gonna you know come through and save
everything it's like you you could never
let your guard down and put yourself
mentally in a position where you're just
like gonna be free sailing for the rest
of your life i mean obviously we all
want that but to think that tyranny is
just somehow just gonna you know
disappear and it's never going to pop
its head up that's just a literally
naive you know way of thinking and and
in my opinion the the the independent
media moderates libertarians
conservatives you know whatever this
faction is i don't like saying the right
because not everybody is but we need
something like there's this app called
thunderclap
where you would all what you would do is
you would sign up for it you'd click a
button and then it would be like do you
accept the terms if you put yes
on the same day at the same time
everyone who agreed would tweet out it
would take take your twitter account and
tweet out the exact same message causing
them an instant trend it was called
thunderclap
there needs to be something like this to
help people organize the left has
institutions that help them organize and
remain organized
the right and the liberty-minded people
need something similar so that you can
very easily direct some kind of action
on things
because right now it's it's so fractured
and just across the board that's
difficult when you're an individualist
of course you're not going to be as
organized as a cult
yeah you know i had an interesting
interaction the other day i don't know
the name of the company but where i live
they want to install
all of this remote access to like your
thermostat into your your your air in
your house and even to the point of like
getting into your gated community like
it's all accessed through your phone
and like they approached me and they're
like hey you need you need to sign this
paper
so we can come in and have your consent
to
you know remote access your thermostat
to remote access uh data in your phone
to have all the data from your phone
that we can collect for this company so
that we can have that on a daily basis
like i'm sitting there
and like she's like expecting me to be
stupid she's like oh you just need to
sign it it's going to be convenient
because then you'll be able to just
access you know the gated community with
your phone the thermostat you can access
it from your home and it's like it's an
entire smart home right and i'm like
it was interesting
because i'm sitting there i'm reading
i'm reading the contract before i sign
my name on the line
and the first thing it says is you are
giving consent to the provider
and to the
uh the owner right to have remote access
to all of this technology out of your
phone and then it gets even worse and
it's like you are also giving consent
to uh give third party data that we
compile
on your phone directly it doesn't even
explain what data
and i'm sitting there reading this and
like i'm like hey
i'm not signing this i was like what
what kind of data like what are you guys
talking about here you're gonna have
remote access to my thermostat i can't
say where i live but you know i'm pretty
sure people will find out where it is
but
like i'm not
that that's how they take it away and
it's like i'm saying this was the
interesting part tim because when i
started like saying that pushing back
and asking questions she came in and she
was like
yeah you know the lawyers told us that
you know if there are people that think
it's kind of weird
and they push back they told me to just
let them know and i'm like
so if i don't sign this am i gonna get
kicked out where i'm living she's like
no it's fine we just wanted to see how
many signatures we could get wow
well they already started doing this at
my apartment i came back one day and
they replaced my my key lock with one of
those touch pads so they can get in at
any time and look at the apartment and
you know i'm sure it's i already signed
it away
when i first signed but i think this
this points to the bigger cultural
phenomenon
that we've been sold on this this
society of convenience
uh and it's a lie it's it's a total hoax
right that if you get something more
convenient then you're going to be
happier
and this has been happening forever
right we went from the fax machine to
the email or the
horse buggy to the car and all these
modes of communication transportation
that are supposed to make our lives
better and more convenient
are we any less stressed are we any less
anxious are we any less busy and so
people already know and they've already
seen that we will sell our
our freedoms for convenience so why not
push it a little bit further why not put
a microchip in your body and that'll
help you read your own your own body
levels better and your blood level and
they talked about this at the world
economic forum it's not just that but it
goes the other way too there's a
there's a video of a guy
in like the early 1900s
and he was around in this during the
civil war a really really old man and
they asked him at the time like
how do you feel about how technology has
changed from when you were a kid till
now because in their minds like the
automobile wow how crazy you know from
back in when the civil war and he said
oh it's the same it's all the same you
know people were happy people are happy
then people are happy now
people had to get stuff they're stressed
then they're stressed now it was things
like that and you know i think about
that
we look at the technology we have right
now and act like everything's so great
but in 50 years you know maybe we will
have hover packs and flying cars and
teleportation or who knows what we're
not stressed out that we can't teleport
right now we're not sitting here being
like i can't teleport life sucks we just
where maybe when you're in traffic on
the freeway maybe maybe but what i mean
is
a dude people who lived in the 1700s
were satisfied with the level of
technology they had it was all they knew
and as things got better people adapted
to those better things
that's what the world economic forum
sees
they see that people in 1850 they were
happy they didn't need air conditioning
sure some like there was there was
sadness people died of like you stubbed
your toe and get an infection and die
but nowadays
people have become so spoiled and
egotistical and the example i'll give is
healthcare
there are people saying healthcare is a
human right
and my my immediate logical you know
rebuttal is if the technology doesn't
exist to cure someone is it your right
the answer is no but then if the
technology gets invented and one cure is
made because it was just invented who
has that right to it
technology so this is this is the issue
the one that gonna form sees that human
beings can be happy with things being
taken away from them and that's their
goal put everybody back down to the to
the early 1900s 1800s level of
technology they'll adapt to it they'll
adhere and they'll be happy and then
we'll sit atop elysium with our flying
cars yeah while they continue to
innovate move forward and control
there's a level oh of convenience you're
mentioning where like they're replacing
your locks on your door so that they can
get access like it would be convenient
if uh someone slipped into my shower and
washed my back for me in my armpits but
i'm not into it i don't need it thanks
no don't need that level of convenience
yeah but it's my house if you look at
these excerpts from books or whatever
articles from 50 100 years ago
and they asked people what do you think
the technology is going to be like in
100 years they do talk about flying cars
and hover pads but it goes to what you
were saying that you know the elite are
going to have that the elite can have
access to that but it's not for the
masses right the masses get the
bluetooth toaster and the fridge that
talks to you it's like why do i need a
bluetooth why do i need a fridge that
talks to me but people like it and the
masses are sold on that thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and if you
want more special access content head
over to timcast.com and become a member
your membership helps sustain this
company keep our journalists employed
makes this show happen and you will get
access to exclusive members only
segments of the tim cast irl podcast and
there's a massive library to check out
so again go to timcast.com or tune in
monday through friday at 8pm and we'll
see you all there